y soy una somalí-estadounidense musulmana y de color, procedente de Kenia.
(Aplauso)
Dicen que soy una pionera,
fui la primera reina musulmana del baile de mi bachillerato,
la primera senadora somalí estudiantil en mi universidad
y la primera mujer en portar el hiyab en muchos sitios,
como en el concurso de belleza de Señorita Minnesota en EE. UU.
las pasarelas de Milán y las Semanas de la Moda de Nueva York,
e incluso en la histórica portada de la "Vogue" británica.
Como ven,
no me preocupa ser la primera y salir por mi cuenta,
arriesgarme y buscar el cambio
porque en eso consiste ser minoría.
Se trata de usarse a sí mismo para propiciar un cambio
y de ser una representante humana del poder de la diversidad.
Ahora, utilizo mi posición para difundir un importante mensaje de aceptación.
Pero no siempre ha sido fácil.
Cuando llegamos a EE. UU., hicimos de St. Louis, Missouri, nuestro hogar,
me acuerdo de que le pregunté a mi madre: "¿De verdad esto es EE. UU.?".
Había cosas que me resultaban tristemente familiares,
como oír disparos por la noche
o las calles de aspecto empobrecido.
Pero también había cosas que eran muy diferentes,
como cuando empecé la primaria.
Noté que los niños jugaban en grupos.
En EE. UU., lo llaman "pandillas".
Aquí, todos jugábamos juntos.
Tu sexo no importaba,
y tu raza, sin lugar a dudas, tampoco.
Recuerdo que me preguntaba:
"¿Por qué no entienden suajili?
El suajili es el idioma que une a los pueblos".
Para colmo de males,
el colegio en el yo estaba no tenía ningún programa de inmersión en inglés.
Así que todos los días, me levantaba,
iba al colegio, me sentaba en mi pupitre
y no aprendía nada.
Ahí empecé a perder la esperanza
y solo deseaba regresar a Kakuma,
al campo de refugiados.
Pronto, mi madre descubrió que muchos somalíes hallaron asilo
en un pueblecito de Minnesota.
Y cuando cumplí ocho años, nos mudamos a Minnesota.
Mi vida cambió en cuanto conocí a otros estudiantes que hablaban somalí,
fui a un colegio con un programa de inmersión en inglés
y encontré profesores que hacían lo imposible,
se quedaban después de clases y en los recreos,
dedicados a ayudarme a triunfar en clase.
Ser una niña refugiada me enseñó que a uno podían despojarlo de todo:
de la comida, de la vivienda, del agua potable,
incluso de la amistad,
pero lo único que nadie podría quitarnos jamás
sería la educación.
Así que mi prioridad principal fueron los estudios
y pronto, comencé a prosperar en clase.
A medida que fui creciendo, tomé conciencia de otras personas
y de lo que opinaban de mi raza y de mi pasado.
Específicamente, cuando empecé a portar el velo en la cabeza llamado hiyab.
Cuando empecé a usarlo, estaba emocionada.
Recuerdo cómo admiraba el de mi madre y quería emular su hermosura.
Pero cuando comencé la secundaria,
los alumnos se burlaban y me decían que no tenía cabello,
y para demostrarles lo contrario,
les enseñaba mi cabello,
lo cual va en contra de mis creencias, pero me sentí presionada a hacerlo.
Yo quería encajar con todas mis fuerzas.
Al reflexionar sobre cuestiones de raza, religión o identidad,
me vienen a la mente muchos recuerdos dolorosos.
Podría acusar fácilmente a los de otras culturas
de hacerme sentir ese dolor,
pero pensándolo bien,
también reconozco que los hechos más impactantes,
positivos y que cambiaron mi vida, me ocurrieron
gracias a toda esa gente que es diferente a mí.
Fue entonces cuando decidí salir de mi zona de confort
y competí en un certamen portando el hiyab y el burkini.
Lo vi como una oportunidad para hablar por las mujeres
que, como yo, no se sentían representadas.
Y aunque no conseguí la corona,
esa experiencia me abrió muchas puertas.
Recibí correos y mensajes de mujeres de todo el mundo
diciéndome que mi autenticidad les había servido de inspiración.
Otros "debuts" siguieron llegando.
Carine Roitfeld, icono de la moda, me invitó a Nueva York
para rodar mi primera sesión de editorial.
En esa época me convertí en la primera modelo con hiyab
y en mi primer año,
adorné las portadas de nueve revistas de moda.
Fue sensacional, por decir algo.
Pero a pesar de ese éxito tan repentino,
hubo algo que no cambió:
la idea de poder regresar aquí a Kakuma,
el lugar al que llamo mi hogar.
Y tan solo unos meses después, me sucedió algo increíble.
Estaba en Nueva York, en una sesión de fotos,
cuando conocí a la modelo sursudanesa Adut Akech
quien también nació aquí en Kukuma.
Esa experiencia en sí, es la mejor definición de esperanza.
Imagínense,
dos niñas que nacieron en el mismo campo de refugiados
se juntan por primera vez en la portada de la "Vogue" británica.
(Aplauso y ovación)
Tuve el gran honor de asociarme con UNICEF
sabiendo de primera mano el trabajo que hacen por los niños necesitados.
Quisiera que se acuerden
de que los niños aquí refugiados,
siguen siendo niños.
Se merecen todas las oportunidades para prosperar, tener esperanza, soñar
y triunfar.
Mi historia comenzó justo aquí, en el campo de refugiados de Kakuma,
un lugar de esperanza.
Gracias.
(Aplauso)